Transcriber: zeliha yıldırım
Gözden geçirme: Erman Turkmen
Durukan Dudu
Çoban
Özellikle bizim kuşağın bu çağda
bir iç sıkıntısı var.
Hani dövüş klübü filmini ya da
kitabını görenler olduysa
orada bir iç sıkıntısından bahseder ve
ve biz büyük buhran yaşamadık
savaşlar yaşamadık, böyle bir nesiliz
ne yaptığımızı pek de bilmiyoruz
gibi bir mesaj verir.
Günümüzde bu duygunun içerisindeyiz biraz.
Ekolojik kriz artık bir
sohbet konusu olmanın ötesinde
böyle frenleri boşalmış bir kamyon gibi
lümbür lümbür gittiğimiz bir
çıkmaz sokak haline dönüştü.
Ekonomik olarak deseniz
bizden önceki kuşakların
en azından bir emekli olurum,
hayat güzel olur düşüncesi vardı
bizim pek öyle bir inancımız ve
güvencemiz de yok, hissetmiyoruz.
Toplumsal krizler azalmıyor, devam ediyor.
Güzel gelişmelere rağmen
hani büyük resim diyorlar ya,
büyük resimde bir şeyler sanki sıkıntılı.
Bir de bunun üzerine aslında biz hep
çok özel olduğumuz mesajı ile büyüyoruz.
Reklamlarda, okullarda, televizyonlarda,
toplumun her alanında
sürekli bir her şey olabilirsiniz deniyor.
Ama olmak istediğimiz şeyi olabileceğimize
pek de emin değiliz.
Her şey olabiliz ama
olmak istediğimiz şeyler hariç belki de.
Bir nevi bekleme sırasında gibi
hissediyoruz belki de.
Kendi hissiyatlarımı da paylaşıyorum
sizlerle şu anda.
Bir bekleme sırasındayız,
sıranın nereye gittiği
hakkında hiçbir fikrimiz yok.
Eğitim durumumuza ya da aile durumumuza
geçmişimize göre bir yerden
o sıraya konulmuşuz,
belli bir hızda ilerliyoruz
ve canımız sıkılıyor
çünkü anlamlandıramıyoruz,
yabancılaşıyoruz.
Bir yandan ayrılamıyoruz da bu sıradan
çünkü bir şeyleri kaybetme korkusu var,
yalnız kalma korkusu var.
O yüzden de belki birileri gelse de
bir şeyler olsa da
sıra darmadağın olsa diyoruz.
Böylelikle bizim sıradan
ayrılmamıza gerek kalmayacak
sıra kendiliğinden yok olacak.
Hatta bu zombi kıyameti temalı filmlerin,
edebiyat eserlerinin bu kadar
yaygınlaşmasının sebebi de bu.
Çok güzel bir gelecek; sıra dağıldı.
Ben de bu hissiyattaydım.
Özellikle üniversitenin ilk yıllarında,
hatta lisenin son yıllarından beri
ekoloji harekenin içinde olan biri olarak
hem Türkiye'de hem Avrupa ölçeğinde
Yeşiller hareketinin içinden biri olarak
bütün bu sayıları, bütün bu gidişatı
özellikle ekoloji konusunda
bilip de umutsuzlanmama ihtimaliniz yok.
Benim bilinçli karamsarlık diye
tanımladığım bir haldesiniz.
Çünkü iklim değişikliğinden örnek verelim.
Bilim insanları pek böyle konularda,
meselelerde anlaşamamaları ile ünlüdür.
O yüzden her sene İsviçreli bilim adamları
bir sene domatesi göklere çıkarırlar,
ertesi sene dünyanın
en kötü gıdası olduğu söylenir.
Ertesi sene bir kez daha
çok iyi bir gıda olduğu anlaşılır.
Ama bilim insanlarının
çok ciddi bir konsensüsle
üzerinde anlaştığı bir mesele var,
o da iklim değişikliği ve diyorlar ki
atmosferdeki karbondioksit oranı
350'yi geçerse -milyonda 350 parçacık
teknik bir terim-
bu medeniyetin, insanlığın, tüm yaşamın
dediğim gibi freni boşalmış bir kamyon
gibi devriliyor olduğunun
yokuş aşağı gidiyor olduğunun kanıtıdır.
Şu anda kaçta olduğumuzu bilen var mı?
Eminim vardır ama 400.
350 geçilmemesi gereken eşikti,
şu anda 400'deyiz.
Bu sayı azalmıyor, tersine artıyor.
Bütün bunları bilip de
umutsuzlanmamak mümkün değil.
Hayatın anlamı nedir, ben niye yaşıyorum
diye sorgulamamak mümkün değil
varoluşsal sıkıntıyla birlikte.
Sonra hayatımda bir şey oldu.
Yüksek lisans için gittiğim İsveç'te,
tezimi yazdığım çiftlikte bütüncül yönetim
adında bir şeyle karşılaştım.
Benim de o dönemde gençlerin
kırsala gidiş modellemeleriyle ilgili
çoban olarak olabilir,
ayakkabıcı olarak olabilir
herkes çoban olmak zorunda değil
kafamda somut fikirlerin netleşmeye,
iyice oturmaya başladığı bir dönemdi
ve bütüncül yönetimin algoritması diyeyim
bakış şekli çok hoşuma gitti.
Ama bunun ötesinde çok ilginç ve önemli
bir şey söylüyordu bütüncül yönetim.
İnanması çok zor, insanı doğru olduğundan
korkutacak kadar güzel bir şey söylüyordu.
Diyordu ki çok bereketli, çok verimli,
ekonomik olarak güçlü bir tarım yaparak
bu tarımı yaparken bir yandan dünyayı,
ekosistemi, doğayı onarmak mümkün.
Bu, çok net bir şekilde söylüyorum sizlere
son iki yüzyılın en büyük, önemli iddiası.
Tarım konusunda değil,
bütün dünyayı alın en önemli iddiası.
Sürdürülebilirlik alanında çalışanların
yüzlerindeki şaşkınlık ifadesini
göremiyorum ama tahmin edebiliyorum.
Çünkü tarım bizim doğadaki en güçlü
tahakküm aracımız oldu hep bugüne kadar.
Özellikle kimyasal tarımla birlikte
biliyorsunuz toprakların yok olduğunu,
su kaynaklarının kirlendiğini,
iklim değişikliğine sebep olduğunu.
Öyle bir duruma geldi ki mesele
ben o kadar da fazla hırpalamıyorum
sizden bir nebze daha az hırpalıyorum
diyenleri alkışlamaya başladık.
Onlara bir takım isimler vermeye,
iyi tarım demeye başladık.
Burada ise bırakın zarar vermemeyi,
üzerine bir de onarmaktan bahsediyor.
Bu müthiş bir iddia,
inanması güç ve korkutucu bir iddia.
Çok güzel çünkü.
Ben de inanmadım, sorguladım.
Zaten ailem sağolsun çok severler
benim bu sorgulama işimi
Çobanlık hikayesi de biraz oradan başladı.
Sorguladım ve araştırmaya başladım.
Bir yandan bütüncül yönetim
dünyanın dört bir köşesinde
Afrika'dan Avrupa'ya,
Kuzey Amerika'dan Avustralya'ya
binlerce insan tarafından yapılan
ve çok ciddi ve olumlu sonuçlar
alınan bir mesele.
Bunun üzerine saatlerce konuşabilirim ama
iki tane fotoğraf göstererek
ben özetlemek istiyorum durumu
Bu fotoğraf; ölüm demek, erozyon demek
gıda krizi demek, iklim değişikliği demek
yaşamın bitmesi demek.
Ortadaki göle aldanmayın,
iki günlük yağmur yağmış birikmiş
3 gün sonra buharlaşıp gidecek,
çöl demek ölüm demek.
Bütüncül yönetimle onarıcı tarım yaparak
bu özel örnekte hayvancılık yaparak
gelinen nokta ise bu.
Bu ise yaşam demek,
iklim değişikliğinin bitmesi demek
gıda demek, keyif demek her şeyden önce
yeşil demek, insanın içinin gülmesi,
gözlerinin gülmesi demek.
Neyse bu hikayeme devam edeceğim
ama öncesinde unutturmayın
gerçekten heyecanlı bir yermiş burası.
Şunu söylemek istiyorum;
Bu 3 sene içerisinde anladığım bir şeyi
paylaşmak istiyorum unutmadan.
O da şu, canınız sıkılmasın demiyorum,
hobi olarak yine sıkılın.
Arada keyifli oluyor hakikaten ama
bir çok insanın söylediğine veya
bizlerin hissettiğine tam ters olarak
insanlığın en şanslı dönemindeyiz,
en şanslı kuşaklarıyız.
Çünkü insanlık tarihinin hiçbir noktasında
yapılması gerekenler, yapılabilir olanlar
ve yapılması varoluşsal tatmin verenler
hiç bu kadar üst üste binmemiş,
bu kadar örtüşmemiş,
bu kadar birbirini sarmalamamıştı.
Bunun üstüne biraz düşünmenizi
rica ediyorum.
Hollywood filmlerinde bir klişe vardır
bir noktada bir kahraman gelir ve der ki
sen seçilmiş kişisin,
insanlığın kaderi senin ellerinde.
Gezegen her birimize
yaşımız ne olursa olsun,
eğitimimiz, yaptığımız iş ne olursa olsun
her birimize her an bunu fısıldıyor
şu anda, duymasını bilirsek.
Bugüne kadar hiç sahip olmadığımız
olanaklar var bugün
bilgiler var, internet var,
bütüncül yönetim var
diğer onarıcı tarım pratikleri var.
Bütün bunları yapmak
çok keyif verici, çok tatmin edici.
Türkiye'nin son yörük boylarından
bir tanesi olan
Sarı Keçililer'in lideri Pervin ananın
bana söylediği bir şeyi hiç unutmuyorum.
A oğul demişti,
gece merada çobana çıktığın zaman
o koyunların otları yerken
ağızlarından çıkardığı ses var ya
o sesi duyduğunda
hayatın anlamını anlayacaksın.
Eksik söylemiş, fazla söylememiş.
Çok doğru.
Hikayeme geri dönüyorum hemen.
Türkiye'ye döndüm İsveç'ten sonra
ve Tema Vakfı'nda
Çevre Politikaları Koordinatörü
olarak çalışmaya başladım.
Bir yandan da araştırmalarımıza
devam ediyoruz.
Bir bekleme sırasından bahsettik ya
biz o bekleme sırasının yerine
bir şenlik alanı yaratmak istiyoruz
öncelikle kendi hayatlarımızda
sonra belki bu sayede
başka insanların hayatlarına dokunarak.
Bir kolektif şeklinde kırsalda yaşama,
onarıcı tarım yapma hayalleri kuruyoruz.
Bir senenin sonunda
bu hayallerimizi gerçekleştirmeye
karar verdik, kırsala yerleştik.
Tarımın t'sinden anlamıyoruz,
soğan sarımsak nasıl ekilir bilmiyoruz.
Ben o sırada itiraf ediyorum bunu
ilk defa burada,
domatesin yaz mı, kış mı, bahar mı,
ne sebzesi olduğunu bilmiyordum.
Yani kimseye söylemeyin diyeceğim
ama şimdi bir sürü insan duymuş oldu.
Bu iki buçuk sene önceki durum
ve başladık bir şeyler yapmaya
Ardından bir yandan bütüncül yönetim
Allan Savory, Savory Enstitüsü ile
iletişim halindeyiz ve bizi çağırdılar.
Colorado'daki ilk konferanslarına
gittim ben de, masaya oturduk
Dünyanın dört bir yanından büyük çiftçiler
onarıcı tarım yapan insanlarla tanışıyoruz
Biri başladı söze.
Ben bilmem kaç bin hektarda
6 kuşaktır çiftçiyim,
15 senedir bütüncül yönetim yapıyorum
az tabi biliyorum, daha çok yeniyim
Ben böyle bakıyorum
Bu az dedi şimdi,
bir dakika yanlış duymadım değil mi diye.
İşte bir sonraki aynı, bir sonraki aynı.
Bana geldi dedim ki
çok açık konuşacağım sizlerle.
Tarımın t'sinden, toprağın t'sinden
anlamıyorum, bilmiyorum.
Hayvancılıktan anlamıyorum.
Bu tam iki sene öncesi.
Uzaktan baksam koyunla keçiyi
ayıramam ondan anlayın yani,
dolayısıyla bana bu işi yapmak için,
bu işin içine girmek için,
bu serüvene katılmak için
git toprak öğren öyle gel,
hatta yaşın yetmez bu noktadan sonra
çocuğunu gönder diyorsanız
söyleyin ben gideceğim odama
2-3 gün ağlarım, sızlarım,
bir noktada kendimi toparlarım,
aşk acısı gibi bu acıda geçer,
giderim hayatıma
yeni bir güzergah çizerim,
hayallerime başka bir yolla
yaklaşmaya çalışırım dedim.
Herkes sandalyeleri falan devirip
hayır dur, olamaz dedi gerçekten.
Dediler ki toprak işin kolay kısmı.
İnsan, en önemli kısım insan.
İnsan meselesini çözmeniz lazım.
İnsan meselesini çözmeniz için
-çünkü o zaman toprağı çözmek
çok kolay, çok hızlı-
insan meselesini çözmeniz için
kendinizi çözmeniz lazım.
Tedx’in de bu sene söylediği gibi
yeniden keşfetmeniz lazım.
Önyargılarınızı, ön varsayımlarınızı,
ben kimim sorusunu
neredeyim, ne yapıyorum, niye buradayım
mutlu muyum, yaşadığımı hissediyor muyum
sorularını çözmeniz lazım.
Bunları yaptıktan sonrası
çok kolay dediler.
Ben o an abarttıklarını düşündüm,
işin doğrusu abarttıklarını düşündüm.
Döndüm yeniden Türkiye'ye ve
biz uygulama arazimizde başladık.
Söylemek istediğim insan meselesi
gerçekten çok önemli.
Biz hiçbir şeyimiz olmadan başladık.
Hiçbir şeyimiz hala yok
o şekilde devam ediyoruz
ama birbirimize sahibiz
çekirdek kadromuz olarak.
Bunların başında Volkan geliyor,
benim yoldaş demekten onur duyduğum kişi.
Bunu güçlü bir emel,
yanında güçlü bir niyet
ve bunu bir de amele dönüştürerek,
iş yaparak harmanladığınız zaman
her şey olamayabilirsiniz gerçekten
ama istediğiniz şey olabileceğinize
ben kesinlikle inanıyorum,
ben buna inanıyorum.
Tabi bir yandan insan da değişiyor
oraya da geleceğim ama öncesinde
Çakıl
Bizim evlat edindiğimiz,
barınaktan aldığımız köpeğimiz.
Köydeyiz ve yaz gelmiş artık,
domates ekiyoruz.
O zamana kadar öğrenmişim artık
domatesin yazın ekildiğini.
Gübreye ihtiyacımız var fide yapmak için,
Gittik bizim 71 model emektar
kertenkele lakaplı traktörümüzün arkasına
römork koyduk, doldurduk getirdik
gübreyi eliyoruz sabahtan akşama kadar.
Ve aşağıya bir toprak dökülüyor ki
insan bir garip oluyor
içine girmek istiyor toprağın,
yüzüne sürmek istiyor,
yemek istiyor o toprağı.
Tam böyle Volkan'la
birbirimize bakmaya başladık
ya bizde mi bir gariplik mi
var acaba diye.
Biz bu soruyu sorarken
Çakıl atladı toprağa ve yemeye başladı.
O an dedik biz de bir gariplik yokmuş.
Dedik ki tamam amaç belli işte
çok da düşünmeye gerek yok
dünyanın hadi dünyayı
belki o kadar etkilemeyebiliriz
vize falan çıkarmazlar belki
ama en azından
Türkiye'nin bütün topraklarını
bu toprağa dönüştürmek.
Amacımız bu olsun.
Bundan güzel amaç mı olur dedik.
Tabi çok imkansız gibi duruyor ama,
burada 68 kuşağının sloganını
ters çevirerek kullanıyoruz
imkansızı iste, gerçekçi ol diyoruz.
Ardından çoban da olduk,
ufaktan koyun sürüsü yapmaya başladık.
Bugün 200 dekar uygulama arazimizde
yaptığımız şey bu.
Bütüncül yönetim uyguluyoruz hayvanlarla,
bizzat kendimiz çobanız.
Beraber kolektif yaşamanın
güzel yanı da burada.
Volkan ve diğerleri
şu anda koyun başındayken
ben burada sizlerle sohbet edebiliyorum.
Arazimizde yaklaşık organik madde
miktarını senede %0,2 arttırmak,
verimi de %30-40 civarında
arttırmak hedefimiz var.
Bu hedef yolunda şu anda
hiç bir sorun olmadan ilerliyoruz.
Bu sayılar ne demek?
Verim hadi belli, %30 her sene artıyor.
3 sene sonra kümülatif olarak baktığınızda
%150 artmış olacak mesela.
Organik madde ise şu demek;
eğer herkes bütüncül yönetim yaparsa,
%0,2 dedik ya yılda arttırır
bugün doğan bir bebek
benim yaşıma geldiğinde
iklim değişikliğini ancak
tarih kitaplarında okur.
Biter.
Bugün 400 diyoruz ya,
-350 güvenli noktaydı-
280’lere sanayi devrimi öncesine düşer.
Bu, olup olabilecek en müthiş dünya demek.
En bereketli, en bolluklu ve ekolojik
krizlerin en olmadığı dünya demek.
Bunu yapmazsak bugün doğan bir çocuk
benim yaşıma geldiğinde
eğer hala nefes alabiliyorsa
yani hayattaysa, ölmediyse
kendini dünyanın en şanslı %5 -10
nüfusundan biri olarak tanımlar.
Ama belki de ölseydim de kurtulsaydım der.
Aradaki fark bu.
O yüzden aslında
gıda üretimi dediğimiz zaman
çobanlık veya gıda üretimi genelde
birilerinin yapması gereken bir iştir ya.
Ben şunu söylüyorum; gıda üretimi
hele hele onarıcı gıda üretimi
o kadar önemli ki dünyanın -bu kelimeyi
çok sevmememe rağmen kullanacağım-
en parlak beyinlerinin
yapması gereken bir iş.
En önemli işi, en kritik işi.
Yediğiniz şey, içinize aldığınız ve
sizi yeniden var eden şey.
Ne yiyorsak o'yuz.
Buradan hepinize bir çağrıda
bulunmak istiyorum aslında.
Bütüncül yönetimin,
onarıcı tarımın çağrısı
dünyanın bugüne kadar gelmiş geçmiş
en epik, en heyecanlı serüven çağrısı.
Bu çağrı bilenler vardır
Yüzüklerin Efendisi kitabında ve
filmindeki gibi bir çağrı.
Kim olursan ol gel diyor.
Şu kadar boylu bir hobit de olabilirsin
kesin bir işe yarayacaksın diyor.
Kocaman, kaslı bir savaşçı da
olabilirsin diyor.
Herkese ihtiyaç duyan bir çağrı ve
çok keyifli bir çağrı
Herkesin kendini ifade etmesini
sağlayabilecek bir çağrı.
Bu çağrıya kulak verelim.
çünkü bu çağrı sadece yapılması gereken
bir şeyi yapma imkanı vermeyecek,
ciddi bir tatmin duygusu
yaratacak hepimizde.
Kim olursanız olun herkese ihtiyaç var.
Sanatçılar, akademisyenler, sivil toplum,
şirketler, bireyler, ev kadınları
ev erkekleri, terziler, ayakkabıcılar
permakültürcüler, herkese ihtiyaç var.
Herkesin yapabileceği bir şey var.
Siz de bu serüvene dahil olun
çünkü tren kaçmıyor.
Tren kaçması diye bir şey yok.
Yaşınız, mesleğiniz ne olursa olsun
bir yerden dahil olabilirsiniz buna.
En keyifli iş bu.
Ama şunu unutmayın lütfen,
bizi çağrımız da bu.
Eş kurucusu olduğum
Anadolu Meraları'nın çağrısı da bu.
Bütüncül yönetimin ve Savory Enstitüsünün
Türkiye'deki temsilcisi olan
Anadolu Meraları'nın çağrısı bu.
Dahil olun bu serüvene ama
Howard Thurman'ın dediği gibi;
Dünyanın neye ihtiyaç duyduğunu düşünüp
onu yapmaya çalışmayın.
Sizi yaşam enerjisi ile dolduran,
yaşadığınızı hissettiren şeyi yapın.
Çünkü dünyanın esas ihtiyacı
yaşadığının farkında olan
yaşam enerjisi dolu insanlardır.
Teşekkür ederim.
(Applause)